i try to write a poem and i am pretty
nervous uh but i will do my best
my wiener is chill man it ain't trying
to do no crime
it ain't even that hard a lot of the
time and that's true actually because a
lot of times i'll get like those
wiener pills from the gas station you
know what i'm talking about them real
giraffe makers you know
make my legs sweat actually my wiener is
trill
my wiener is candid it looks like joe
pesci it's that wet bandit
um but i'm lit to the fact that girls
are far more than sex
they are champions and soldiers with
power in their breasts
they are creative and equal and warm and
life-bringing
i love dolly parton but it's because of
her singing
my wiener is chill man it ain't trying
to do crime
it ain't even that hard a lot of the
time my wiener
ain't weinstein my wiener aunt cosby but
sometimes it wishes for a little bit of
a jobs being you feel me
hello uh this is uh poems called
uh things i thought of today
[Laughter]
i'm a man sort of and i try to do right
like
rosie o'donnell taking a small bite
she's a she's a big girl
but it's so confusing to know what to
think and what to say
if only i wasn't an atheist at least i
could pray
okay uh i used women for sex
and some have used me they seem
depressed
[Laughter]
so we're all the same except you sit
when you pee
and you can't spell woman without men
and there's no men
without woman so i guess at the end of
the day we're all just
pieces of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
thank you
so i don't dislike feminists i don't
dislike feminists i just don't want to
hear their poetry
there were moments that i enjoyed and
there were moments that i had also fear
but at least we learned something you
know we didn't
i think i learned a little bit during
the day with the group i think they
became more accepting you became works i
became more accepting
and then the poetry ruined it all and
now i'm back to where i [ __ ] started
i'll say this i learned that they laugh
at a lot more stuff than i thought they
would i didn't think that they would
laugh at anything but i wasn't i
i think they most of them were seeing
pretty
i don't even know i'm dumber for hearing
that sentence
yeah today was a really good day i got
to take one of my heroes
into you know snatch ganastan and
really see what was going on with some
feminists
and in the end i think we both learned
some stuff we learned that some
feminists are cool
it takes a lot of fabric and extra
textiles to make one of those
vajastums and three i really like uber
select
and then i'll tip my driver the same
whether they're male
or female can i have permission to hug
yeah you know